Ein Leben auf der Venus - völlig undenkbar.
Mit einer Durchschnittstemperatur von rund
460 Grad Celsius ist es dort nicht nur heiß
genug, um Blei zu schmelzen.
Ihre Atmosphäre besteht zudem auch zum größten
Teil aus Kohlendioxid.
Doch in der Vergangenheit sah die Venus offensichtlich
ganz anders aus - bedeckt mit Ozeanen und
somit vielleicht sogar bewohnbar.
Ein Forschungsteam aus Wales hat jetzt herausgefunden,
warum sich der Planet wohl Stück für Stück
zu der heutigen Höllenlandschaft entwickelt
hat.
Tja und da liegen die Gedanken an die aktuelle
Entwicklung hier auf der Erde ja nicht so
fern.
Allerdings ist der Grund für die Entwicklung
auf der Venus belegbar ein ganz anderer.
Clixoom Science & Fiction - Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Science-Videos, abonniert den
Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr nichts. herzlich
willkommen!
Das ist wirklich eine kuriose Vorstellung:
Die Venus mit einer deutlich kühleren Oberfläche
als heute - und zudem noch bedeckt von zahlreichen
Ozeanen.
Ein Planet also, auf dem Leben einst sehr
gut vorstellbar wäre.
Genau davon geht jetzt eine neue Studie eines
Forschungsteams aus Wales aus.
Demnach könnte der Planet tatsächlich eine
ganze Zeit lang äußerst lebensfreundliche
Umweltbedingungen geboten haben.
Venus soll in diesem Stadium sogar der Erde
ziemlich ähnlich gewesen sein.
Zusammen mit Experten und Expertinnen der
NASA und Forschungs-Kolleginnen und Kollegen
aus Washington führte das Team Simulationen
an einem numerischen Gezeitenmodell durch.
Hierbei wurde vor allem der Einfluss potentieller
Ozeane unterschiedlicher Tiefe auf die Rotationsgeschwindigkeit
des Planeten unter die Lupe genommen.
Wie die Fachleute aus Wales jetzt in ihrer
Studie schreiben, haben die Ozeane der Venus
damals wie eine Art Bremse auf die Rotationsgeschwindigkeit
des Planeten eingewirkt.
Die vorhandenen Ozeane haben also dafür gesorgt,
dass sich die Drehung der Venus deutlich verlangsamt
hat.
Vereinfacht gesagt ist dies auf die Reibung
zurückzuführen, die bei Flut und Ebbe zwischen
einem Ozean und dem Meeresboden wirkt.
Dazu Matthias Green, der an der Studie beteiligt
war: “Tatsächlich hätte diese “Gezeitenbremse”
die Venus innerhalb von zehn bis 50 Millionen
Jahren von einer erdähnlichen Rotationsgeschwindigkeit
auf ihr heutiges Drehtempo verlangsamen können.
(...) Diese Arbeit zeigt, wie wichtig Gezeiten
sein können, um die Rotation eines Planeten
zu verändern und wie wichtig Gezeiten sind,
um einen Planeten bewohnbar zu machen”.
Und die Folge dieser “Gezeiten-Bremse”
ist bis heute zu beobachten: die sogenannte
retrograde Rotation der Venus.
Im Klartext heißt das, dass sich der Planet
im Vergleich zu unserer Erde in die entgegengesetzte
Richtung dreht.
Doch nicht nur das: Die Venus dreht sich nicht
nur “verkehrt” herum, sondern auch mit
einer langsamen Drehgeschwindigkeit.
Um sich einmal um sich selbst zu drehen, braucht
der Planet 243 Tage lang.
Genau diese langsame Drehgeschwindigkeit verhindert
jetzt wiederum, dass flüssige Ozeane auf
ihr existieren können.
Auch auf der Erde und ihren Ozeanen wirken
letztere übrigens wie eine Art Bremse auf
die Rotation unseres Planeten - allerdings
in einem wirklich sehr kleinen Ausmaß.
In einer Million Jahren wird so ein Tag um
lediglich 20 Sekunden verlängert.
Abgesehen von diesen neuen Erkenntnissen macht
die Studie eine weitere Sache deutlich: Die
Venus wurde lange von der Forschung vernachlässigt.
Doch das ändert sich gerade.
Schon 2023 möchte die “Indian Space Research
Organisation” (ISRO) einen Orbiter zur Venus
starten.
Die NASA überlegt, mit ausgewählten Missionen
ab dem Jahr 2025 zu folgen und auch die Europäische
Weltraumorganisation ESA und die russische
Weltraumagentur Roskosmos haben die Venus
im Visier.
Und das steigende Interesse hat einen Grund:
Nicht wenige Experten und Expertinnen sind
davon überzeugt, dass sie hier eines der
großen Rätsel der Wissenschaft lösen könnten:
Was genau macht einen Planeten bewohnbar?!
Und so werden derzeit mit Hochdruck Technologien
entwickelt, die den schrecklichen Bedingungen
auf der Venus trotzen könnten.
Falls die Venus aber mit großen lebensfreundlichen
Ozeanen vielleicht sogar drei Milliarden Jahre
lang tatsächlich wie die Erde ausgesehen
hat, ist auch eine Sache ganz klar: Die Evolution
hatte hier genug Zeit, in Aktion zu treten.
Genügend Zeit also für die Entstehung von
Leben.
Und vielleicht haben besonders hartnäckige
Organismen sogar bis heute überleben können?!
Dazu der US-Astronom Darby Dyar: “Warum
investieren wir so viel Zeit in die Suche
nach Leben auf dem Mars, wenn es dort nur
400 Millionen Jahre lang flüssiges Wasser
gab?
Und dann steht dagegen die Venus mit drei
Milliarden Jahren Wasser - und niemand interessiert
sich für sie”.
Nicht auszuschließen also, dass die Venus
sogar der erste bewohnbare Planet im Sonnensystem
war?!
Dazu der Pariser Astronom Thomas Widemann:
“Das alles könnte der Beginn eines neuen
Jahrzehnts der Venus sein”.
Wird Venus die Erde 2.0?
Terraforming total!
Anklicken, anschauen und Raumzeit Vlog der
Zukunft abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!